at the fish market in france's biggest
fishing port they're nervous
some here say they've already lost
nearly 50 percent of their income after
their boats weren't granted a license to
fish in british waters
what we don't understand is why some
boats were given licenses and others
weren't some of these boats have been
fishing in these waters for generations
the ocean became the latest battleground
between the uk and the european union
under a post-brexit trade deal which
came into force this year
it meant both sides could control who
could fish in their waters
france accuses the uk of unfairly
denying permission to dozens of its
vessels
fishermen and boulongsomer rely on
british waters for their catch but the
relationship goes both ways because for
the british fishing industry france is
the gateway to europe and they depend on
ports like this for access to the
continent
if the uk doesn't resolve the issue
france is threatening to roll out a
series of sanctions including tougher
checks on trucks going to and from the
uk
and preventing british fishing boats
from docking and unloading their catch
the uk says it's considering legal
action if the measures go ahead
the announcement of brexit we knew
there'd be a lot of problems for the
fishing industry what's happening now is
not a surprise and the biggest losers
will be the british fishermen and the
french fishermen
and not just them
there's concern here that thousands of
jobs could be affected including those
who process the fish that's brought
ashore from british boats
what we want is for everyone to be able
to work for everyone to be able to go
anywhere respecting each other's jobs
for us all to have equal rights and work
hand in hand like before
this city is home to a statue that pays
tribute to the close relations between
the uk and france but that
relationship's being sorely tested
and as politicians argue over their
futures some in the fishing community
feel they're being left out at sea
alexia o'brien al jazeera bologna sumer
northern france